IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG WARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: THE HOBBIT PORN PARODY
THE KNOBBIT IS SURE TO BE A
SUCCESS.
SO WE WANT TO GET IN ON THE
STICKY GROUND FLOOR.
SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS "GEEKY
PORN."
"GEEKY PORN."
WHOA!
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE "DEEP SPACE
NINE INCHES" OR "SCROTAL
RECALL."
(LAUGHTER)
OR "THE PHANTOM MAN-ASS."
ANYTHING IN THE GEEKSPHERE THAT
YOU CAN PORNIFY WILL QUALIFY FOR
THIS HASHTAG WAR.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK, AND GO!
GUY BRANUM?
>> REAR ENDERS GAME.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
YEAH!
AND ON THAT NOTE, (BLEEP ) YOU,
ORSON SCOTT CARD!
ALI WONG?
>> INDIANA JONES AND THE TEMPLE
OF POON.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
RON?
>> DR. WHO'S THAT IN MY BUTT?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WHY IS IT BIGGER ON
THE INSIDE?
POINTS TO RON FUNCHES.
GUY BRANUM?
>> TRIPLE X-MEN FIRST ASS.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
OH, WOW, NICE.
NEXT, NEXT.
RON?
>> FAHRENHEIT 69.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
GUY?
>> MY DICK, THE GATHERING.
(LAUGHTER)
IT STARS ZACH EPHRON.
>> Chris: STARRING ZACH EFRON.
POINTS FOR THAT.
YES, POINTS.
RON FUNCHES?
>> LORD OF T HE (BLEEP) RING.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
ALI?
>> BILL NYE THE SCIENCE GUY ON
GUY.
>> Chris: ON THIS GUY?
>> ON GUY BRANUM.
>> Chris: NICE-- POINTS, POINTS.
RON FUNCHES?
>> MEN IN BLACK MEN IN BLACK
MEN.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THESE ARE SO META!
>> Chris: POINTS TO RON FUNCHES.
GUY?
>> DR. REALLY STRANGE LOVE.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
IT GOT A SNORT.
YOU GET 100 POINTS.
RON?
>> STAR WARS, BUT WI TH (BLEEP).
(LAUGHTER)